the weaponization of Justice in America
now the 45th president of the United
States Donald Trump is probably what the
most recognizable person on the face of
the Earth but last night Fulton County
Georgia officials insisted that the
former president take a mug shot now
Trump told Fox News digital that it was
quote not a comfortable feeling
especially when you've done nothing
wrong the process is the punishment but
only part of the punishment you have far
left radical prosecutors trying to put
Donald J Trump behind bars for hundreds
of years they want him to die in prison
why because he dared to challenge the
results of an election now this is
something by the way Democrats have done
virtually every major election that they
lost since 2000. let's take Hillary
Clinton for example she attempted to
delegitimize the 2016 election results
with a dirty Russian disinformation
dossier remember she paid for that from
an ex-foreign spy Christopher Steele
though through money that was an
intentionally mislabeled as a mere legal
expense no it wasn't a legal expense no
mug shot no arrest for Hillary Clinton
our campaign the DNC you know merely
forced to pay a small fine all was
forgiven she got off even easier after
she mishandled troves of top secret
classified documents on private servers
and then of course uh destroyed evidence
the leading and bleach bidding 33 000
subpoenaed emails and uh yeah destroying
hard drives it's in the process along
with devices that may have had copies on
them but according to James Comey no
reasonable prosecutor would ever
prosecute would charge Hillary Clinton
no raids no mug shots of Hillary Clinton
Comey said this about five years before
the FBI raided Mar-A-Lago and the
justice department charged Donald Trump
oh for basically the exact same thing
top secret classified documents that
they thought were mishandled but he was
the president she was a secretary of
state Joe Biden also accused mishandling
as Senator vice president top secret
material stored it in his garage uh the
Penn Biden Center University of Delaware
his beach house and guess what did it in
some cases for decades naturally for Joe
Biden no consequences no mug shot no
raid nothing just the secret of special
counsel investigation going nowhere fast
now this special counsel does anyone
remember his name Robert Herr completely
M.I.A Biden's attorney general mayor
Garland using these investigations to
protect his boss the big guy part of
Joe's uh branch of government the
executive branch shielding the
administration from having to answer any
and all questions it is beyond a
complete force it is dangerous to our
Republic look at David Weiss the newly
appointed special Council pretending to
investigate Hunter Biden Weiss is the
very same prosecutor who intentionally
let the statute of limitations run out
on several serious felonies during a
five-year probe that was little more
than a a stall tactic five years really
now Weiss tried to not even charge
Hunter with any crime at all that was
the plan we were told by the New York
Times that just a week ago and never
seriously investigating legitimate
allegations against Joe Biden himself
remember a credible FBI Source accusing
Joe Biden and Hunter Biden of each
accepting a 5 million dollar bribe from
Barista Holdings that's the Ukrainian
oil Giant and remember it was Joe Biden
that leveraged one billion taxpayer
dollars to get the prosecutor
investigating barisma and his son Hunter
Victor shulkin is his name uh guess what
uh got him fired in six hours Ukraine
got their money and Hunter Biden
continue to get paid for work that he
had no experience in he admitted that
himself anyway Victor shulkin told our
own Brian kill me this on his show One
Nation take a look
I do not want to deal in unproven facts
but my personal conviction is that yes
this was the case they were being bribed
remember the fact that Joe Biden gave
away one billion dollars in uh U.S uh
money in exchange for my dismissal my
firing isn't that alone a case of
corruption
he leveraged the billion gave Ukraine
six hours to fire him they fired that
man in six hours son of a bee they did
it he uh Ukraine got their billion and
Hunter continued to enrich himself when
he had no experience by the way the full
interview will be on Brian's show One
Nation Saturday night at 8pm right here
on the Fox News Channel now you would
think that the FBI and the Biden's
independent doj May seriously
investigate those allegations but
apparently not if you are a prominent
Democrat if your last name is Biden or
Clinton the justice system will shield
you from any and all scrutiny no matter
what crimes you are being accused of
committing but if you're a Republican
and God forbid your last name is Trump
they will try to ruin your life all
while they're friends in the media mob
They're laughing they're cheering
they're celebrating take a look his
height is listed as six foot three
and his weight is listed
175.
215. 63 215 people pointed out as the
exact dimensions of Lamar Jackson the
quarterback for the Baltimore Ravens I
don't know if the control room as a Mark
Jackson I mean the resemblance is on
campus and if that's what you're trying
to say I think
I feel like an hour and 20 minutes ago I
said the whole thing is a sham
an that's the whole thing do we know who
entered the hair color is that Donald
Trump
description of the haircut I've never
seen in a government document like you
know like buying a fishing license or
something you have to like there's like
drop down menus like things to choose
between
strawberry is an option to render the
American
constitutional Republican structure of
judicial Independence null and void but
for the purpose of getting him up but he
doesn't know that part of the sentence
right he I swear he does but he was a
lot of syllables yeah he looked like
he'd been beat up
I mean yeah
the mug shot has looms so large over the
Fulton County proceedings I think it's
boom so large like anticipation 100 mug
shot when are we gonna see the mug shot
does no one at the Washington Post the
New York Times Ms DNC fake news CNN they
not have any courage to ask questions in
terms of the actions of their government
oh wait they lied they peddle conspiracy
theories for a living starting with the
Russia hoax we should know better Joe
Biden is literally fundraising now off
the Trump booking in Atlanta meanwhile
after writing a puff piece on the Boston
bomber Rolling Stone magazine is now
celebrating Donald Trump's mug shot
msdnc's well she used to be a republican
Nicole Wallace tried to hold back a big
smile describing the violent conditions
at the Fulton County Jail
seems like very objective coverage from
a real journalist take a look he's on
route to Fulton County Georgia via
Newark Airport we believe he will
surrender himself for processing at an
overcrowded jail with a reputation for
violence and neglect a jail that is
accustomed to holding defendants facing
charges up to and including violent
crimes where stabbings are frequent and
actually three people have lost their
lives over the last month
that jail
is where the disgraced ex-president of
these United States is heading right now
more kicks and Giggles they don't care
about Justice ethics for them it's about
revenge it's about political power uh
they are left-wing well frankly
militants hell-bent on using even our
justice system to destroy their
political opponents so I guess it's only
fitting that they are president of
choice is this corrupt 80 year old uh
guy that barely knows what day of the
week it is accused of actual bribery uh
who's perpetually on vacation doesn't
doesn't even seem to know uh what to say
about the devastation in Maui for
example or even talk about the fact that
the truth and the reality that it
actually has seven grandchildren hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else